what are the best practices that fox can
bring to Time Warner
well the global is is the real issue and
you have to look at Time Warner as being
a almost a shadow of what it was ten
years ago it's really now HBO that's the
driver and I think that's the Holy Grail
that Rupert has his eye on because go
HBO they're gonna spin-off CNN because
of the conflict with Fox News so what if
they if they succeed if Rupert gets Time
Warner what he's got is HBO and Warner
Brothers and that's it and he doesn't
need another movie studio 20th Century
Fox's 21st Century Fox is doing great
right now
so it's HBO and and it's a huge money
maker with a huge potential right and
probably the only Netflix killer that
that's in the world right now Porter how
will Walt Disney react to this
transaction there's not a lot they can
do because there's just too much
conflict I mean it'll it'll it'll buoy
the the television and cable interest
that Disney has but they can't be a
competitor the only real competitors are
going to be private equity and the price
I think that Rupert has put on the table
and his willingness to stay here and get
this no matter what it cost is is really
a discouraging effect on any anybody
else he's got such a global distribution
network that he can take advantage of
all of the content and it's really about
contact that that's that's where Rupert
can make the money it's surprising
though that that when he didn't get all
of the sky and and lost a little bit of
the leverage that he had in Europe he
needed to turn somewhere he's going to
is turning to HBO he certainly is Porter
you mentioned distribution that's the
key here because Fox has that time is a
is a content company is this a victory
lap for Brian Roberts and the Comcast
model that combines content with
distribution absolutely it makes Jeff
Buchanan look so smart because he
sighs Time Warner he got would have got
rid of his cable distribution he's spun
out Time Inc the the content company
that was all print and publishing and
he's left with HBO and he hasn't really
to be honest he hasn't done there's not
a lot of innovative management at Time
Warner right now and HBO
really should three or four years ago
realize that Netflix was run away with
the streaming market and which HBO owned
for 25 or 30 years in the atom this is a
25 times free cash flow loot using the
official surveillance at HP 12c
calculate that is a monster prices so
Porter you say effectively say that it's
the network's HBO and perhaps Turner
that are the jewel in the crown but
they're only 20% of revenues so why pay
that kind of number for what is just
one-fifth of the company well he's going
to be able to monetize CNN by spinning
it out he isn't going to be able to keep
two news networks and and CNN is still
making money it's not going anywhere and
and Fox News has killed it in terms of
rating what is CNN worth Porter and
forgive me for interrupting that's a
good question it's it's got have got to
have at least a quarter maybe a third of
the whole value of Time Warner there are
a lot of people who would be very
interested in CNN outside the United so
wait a minute repeat wait a minute so if
Time Warner is it this is a deal Tom
again of what size potentially well
we're over 80 billion in the sky over 80
billion that's right and Porter you
think that that CNN is effectively worth
a quarter of that so 20 billion maybe 20
billion yes you've got it we've got to
consider the franchise that it has and
and the fact that despite the fact that
it's it's got no real audiences anymore
in the United States it's still a global
franchise with profit it's a reflection
of just how much Rupert Murdoch thinks
HBO is worth if that's case amusing
it is I guess it's a game of Thrones
transaction Brad hence with us as well
and the financial side of this merger is
this what Janet Yellen is talking about
I mean if it's immediately accretive
let's explain that what is accretive and
what is dilutive mr. Egan's well if I'm
if I'm bringing my earnings per share
down by an acquisition right you know
essentially I'm looting the shareholders
and in terms of that right if I'm if I'm
increasing it that's that's a creative
you know I think when when you think of
a strategic acquisition like this the
reason the private equity people are
being can can't can't compete is private
equity looks at cash flow in terms of
their evaluation and the corporate
executives can believe in that
fictitious beast synergy and so you know
you can you can get your numbers to look
a lot better if you assume there's a
synergy that's going to somehow occur
from bringing your management teams
together Porter bib can there be
synergies in a fox
we're buying Time Warner is spending so
much can there be a synergy in a Fox
Time Warner combination well sure
there's a lot of redundant expenses if
you fold Warner Brothers into 21st
Century Fox's film and television
operations that's going to be a very
very creative and synergistic mix there
is no HBO as I keep saying is really the
plum yeah in this deal and there's no
synergy because they don't have a pay TV
network at Fox right variety had
reported earlier this week that Google
was also interested in buying Time
Warner Jeff mucus denied knowing
anything about it at Sun Valley where
does this leave Google in terms of
buying up content and being a player
here in these mega merger deals in the
media sector I wouldn't be surprised if
Google didn't snap up CNN it's a perfect
complement to YouTube which is growing
like Topsy right now and it's going to
be a major major content network
distribution system worldwide